here's what's going on at the movies my  name is David pack house I'm 22 years  old and I'm an international arms dealer  the comedy war dogs tells the incredible  true story of two friends who become big  time arms dealers super for homeland  security relax bro my name is Cooper  if you must blink do it now a boy must  battle gods and monsters to save his  family in the animated action adventure  and the two-string give this story happy  what is your name Ben aha in the  amped-up epic Ben Hur a falsely accused  Prince takes revenge on the brother who  enslaved him you die and finally let's  find out what's hot in theaters this  weekend with this week's fan tissa  patient  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket  you